-Our next guest is
a very funny actor you kno
from shows such as "Big Mouth,
"The League"
and "The Good Place."
He stars in season two
of "Close Enough,"
which is available now
on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-Isn't it nice to spend
some time outdoors
with your closest friends?
[ Keyboards clicking,
phones chiming, whooshing
Ugh!
Whatever happened
to human connection?
You'd rather worship
your glowing bricks
than engage with a bon vivan
like myself?
-It's nice to hang out
in the park.
Whoa, bold stance.
-How's this for a big statement?
Phones have ruined society
That's why I keep it old school.
[ Cellphone powering down
-Mom, I'm scared.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Jason Mantzoukas.
How are you, Jason?
Whoo! An entrance!
Look at him go!
-That's right. Boom!
I'm walking in.
-That is --
thank you very much --
like a semblance of normality,
to see a guest
actually walk into the frame
Thank you, buddy.
-You know what?
I don't think I could have
a conversation with you
if I didn't spend some lead-up
time walking towards you.
-I agree.
-So, boom, here we are.
-It is wonderful to
see how animators,
I feel like,
capture your essence.
Because you are a very coveted
voice actor.
And we pulled together jus
some of the people you played.
-What do we got?
-It does seem like,
across the board --
I mean, this is the least
sort of shaggy...
-Yeah.
-...version, but again --
-They all seem to be
some version
of a shirtless crazy person.
-Right.
-You know?
And I love that in "Big Mouth,
too, they have my gray beard
in there.
-Yeah.
-They really want to
show my age.
-Speaking of your beard,
it's really --
it's really something.
-Yeah. Well, I'm going
for a full circle.
I'm growing it out.
Listen, Seth,
I'm not going to lie to you.
I haven't left my God damn house
in a year.
I have lost my mind, okay?
So, I'm going for a full circl
of hair and beard.
That's what I'm aiming for
-That is -- That is
a goal to shoot for.
I wonder, though, what happens
mask-wise
with a beard like that.
-Oh, such a great question
'cause I did, like,
honestly, have to,
like, think about that,
and I made a purchase of a mas
that specifically
covers my beard
and, I feel like,
gives me both protection
and kind of represents
to the outside world
also a little bit
of how I feel on the inside.
Hold on. I'll just -- I'm goin
to grab it and put it on.
It's been great for, like,
when I need to go to the
grocery store or the pharmacy.
-[ Laughing ]
-Is my prescription ready?
Do you have fresh avocados
[ Laughter ]
Please, cover your mouths.
-Oh, wow.
And now, are you seeing throug
the nose or the mouth
when you look through that
-Yes, Seth, I'm looking
through the nose.
-Hey, you have some beautifu
art behind you.
Are those both paintings
on those shelves?
-Oh, yes.
-Okay.
-These are paintings.
These are --
Like I said, I've been hom
alone for a year.
so, like, these are the people
I spend my time with.
These are the people --
If you're wondering, like,
who have you been talking to
for a year, Jason?
Well, I'd love for you to meet
my good friend Peggy,
who looks genuinely nervous.
She looks like -- I feel lik
the look on her face
is like, "Gary,
are you painting me again?
I asked you to not.
please, Gary, stop painting me."
-Right? So, you're spendin
some time with her.
-Spending a lot of time
with Peggy.
She's very unhappily married
She's, like, really pissed off
all the time.
Oh, come on, such a sweet angel.
Such a sweet angel.
Those eyes, Seth, do you think
you'll be able to forget them?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, when you see them
do you know right away
that you have to have them
-Oh, yeah.
There's something that happens
when I see one
where I'm, like --
'Cause I'll buy a lot of them,
like, on, you know, auctions
eBay, or stuff like that,
you know?
Like, one of these
I actually won on an auction
but I'm actually giving it
to Tim Meadows after this.
But, yeah, there's something
about them that, when I see it
I'm like -- No matter how weird,
it doesn't matter.
When I see it, I'm like,
"Ooh, that."
Like, why did I buy this?
Why did I pay money for what i
obviously a child's drawing.
It's not of me.
But the little cowboy
on the shoulder
really, really spoke to me
-I'm so happy, though, because
the person who drew that..
-Yeah.
-...thought when they finished
"Someone is going to buy this,
which is clearly
an insane thought.
-Yeah, lunacy.
-And then you, you validated it.
You made that person sane.
-Ooh.
There is stuff here
that I've been --
that I've had, that I've
been collecting for --
there's a -- Here.
This -- This has been
in every house.
We've known each other
for probably 20 years.
This has been in every apartment
I lived in in New York,
every house I've lived in
in L.A.
It is just a trophy, right
-Yeah.
-Totally normal.
But the engraving says --
Can you read this?
-"Most meals with dad."
[ Laughter ]
-What -- I ask you,
what are the circumstances
that caused that family
to be like,
"You know what we got to do?
We're gonna have to make
a trophy for him
so that he'll, like, calm down
about how few meals
he's having with dad."
[ Laughter ]
What is that?
Not only what is that, not onl
what are the circumstances
that made them make this -
custom-make this trophy,
but then I buy it
and it lives in my kitchen
for decades?
This is, like -- If anything
I think this reflects wors
on me
than the family
that made the trophy.
-I think it reflects pretty well
on all of you.
We're out of time, but I would
maybe like you to come back soon
for something that
we're just gonna call
"Art Beat with Jason."
-Yeah, 100% yes.
-To have a level of collecto
like you join us
was a true honor and privilege
I love you, buddy.
-And, listen, I also am
going to direct you
in "Streetcar Named De-Liar.
Your accent needs work.
-Oh, whoa.
Alright, well, I don't kno
if that is where I thought
that was going.
Season two --
-Yeah, see, right there.
Right there.
-Season two of "Close Enough
is available on HBO Max now.